michael saylor and jack dorsey recently
sat down michael saylor asked jack what
makes bitcoin different why is it that
bitcoin stands alone from all other
cryptocurrencies and this was jack's
exact answer it's deliberate and it's
predictable i mean bitcoin gets a lot of
knocks
especially in the mainstream media
um technology mainstream media versus
ethereum in terms of speed and
development
um ethereum moves very very fast in
comparison um
but it's a question of
you know what is the
ultimate outcome of those moves
um bitcoin is
very deliberate about what goes in and
what stays out and that does
mean it's slower but those slower things
tend to last and they they tend to be a
whole lot more
um predictable in terms of the direction
they're going they tend to be a lot more
secure
they tend to have far better uptime and
usability than anything else
and
that's not to say that there's a ton of
great ideas in the sandbox everywhere
and and happening in all of
all these other projects
um they're great sandboxes that there
will test ideas very very quickly
but that deliberateness is is what makes
bitcoin to me the potential
um for this internet's native currency
and and gives so much confidence
as a business owner as as a as someone
running one of these these companies
that it's
it's going to stick around and it's it's
going to serve billions of people
throughout decades
going forward yeah yeah you can have
lots of innovation a layer too with
projects that compete against lightning
or layer three with applications that
compete against cash app
but i don't have to speculate about
who's gonna inherit
the block corporation in a hundred years
if i do business with you now i i have
the option to to take my level three
assets to a layer two to a layer one
and give them to my grandchildren
and that makes all the difference i
think these are obviously two guys who
completely understand bitcoin and they
are really thoughtful about the way that
they see it moving forward
if you start to think about bitcoin and
the knock against it that whole idea
that bitcoin is slow the development
doesn't actually push the pace of
innovation well part of the point of
bitcoin is that it's going to be around
hundreds of years from today and that
intentionality that durability that
comes from being intentional is one of
the key features when you have a store
of value you need people to remember
that it's going to be here in the future
if you look at something like gold of
course people are willing to put their
wealth into gold because they know gold
is not going anywhere either the problem
with chasing innovation and pushing the
pace as fast as possible when you come
to a durable asset or store a value
asset is that if there's a mistake or
there's some sort of issue you put the
entire thing at risk and so what we're
watching with bitcoin is that bitcoin
continues to simply do what it was
created to do it produces block after
block after block of transactions it
does so in a predictable way the
monetary policy is programmatic and
transparent people around the world what
was first a handful of folks then
millions of folks today tens of millions
and hundreds of millions of folks all
putting their trust in bitcoin as a
store of value as an open monetary
system not because they're blindly
trusting but because they can verify
everything that's happening in that open
transparent system
bitcoin is the future because bitcoin
will be around in the future and that is
why you can trust it to actually store
value now what we've seen is that
there's plenty of people who have all
sorts of arguments or critiques of
bitcoin but bitcoin doesn't care that
block after block after block of
transactions it occurs regardless of
undisciplined monetary or fiscal policy
it happens regardless of what the
mainstream headlines are and it happens
regardless of whether you or i like
bitcoin or not
the system executes exactly as designed
and it continues to be built in a way
that is intentional and that is
optimizing for durability
when i store value i don't want
something that's shiny and sexy i want
something that's durable and strong and
secure
i want something that's going to last
forever
and as we know
somebody like a warren buffett we take
those timeless investing principles
their favorite holding time is forever
so buy great assets and hold them
forever that's why i hold bitcoin it's
up to you to decide what you want to do